[Music]
the sun
beyond just giving us life as if that's
not enough
it also puts on incredible solar shows
like eclipses and flares that can
trigger geomagnetic storms
it's home to temperatures we can't
comprehend and it's the biggest nuclear
engine in our corner of the universe
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream
in this episode of perspectives several
experts discuss some of the marvels that
make our sun so incredible
we start now with an account of where
we'd be without the sun enjoy
[Music]
the sun is by far the biggest and most
massive object in the solar system
in fact
at
99.9 percent of the total mass of the
system you could say the sun is the
solar system the rest is just a wee
sprinkling of dust surrounding it
just try to imagine what would happen if
we magically removed the sun from the
system
darkness would rain temperatures would
plummet and planets would all go flying
off in straight lines from wherever they
were in their orbits
but the sun's importance goes even
further
without the sun
the planets would never have formed
the planet formation process relied on
dust and gas being confined to a disk
orbiting the proto-sun
that disc formed because material was
collapsing onto the proto-sun
thankfully for us
some material had a bit more rotation
making it end up in a disk orbiting
around the sun rather than onto the sun
itself
the sun is an average sized star which
means that it's a large sphere of mostly
hydrogen and helium actually stars such
as our sun that are at least second
generation stars and that means that
they formed following the supernova
explosion of at least one previous star
have compositions that generally
resemble the average composition of the
milky way galaxy
the composition of the ordinary matter
of the milky way not taking into account
strange stuff like dark matter and dark
energy is
74 hydrogen 24 helium
1 oxygen and everything else rocks
metals makes up the last 1
the composition of our sun is about the
same
we're taught in an early age not to look
directly at the sun because of the
potential damage to our eyes
luckily solar telescopes can photograph
the sun through various filters in
different wavelengths of light
when we choose a particular wavelength
of light to study the sun
we are looking at different parts of the
sun's surface and atmosphere
the wavelength is related to the
temperature which is related to specific
parts of the sun for example
the yellowish light we see in the
visible part of the spectrum comes from
the opaque surface of the sun where
radiation has a temperature of about 5
800 kelvin
we would have to wait until the early
20th century for einstein's famous e
equals m c squared equation to tell us
that matter can be converted to energy
that's what happens at the center of the
sun
the pressures and temperatures are so
high in the center of the sun
that hydrogen atoms are squeezed
together fusing to make helium atoms
all the energy we are getting from the
sun comes from nuclear fusion occurring
in the sun's core
this is possible because the four
hydrogen atoms are slightly more massive
than the resulting helium atom
the difference in mass between one
helium and four hydrogen atoms is
converted to energy that energy equaling
the mass difference times the speed of
light squared
the inner 25 percent of the sun converts
over 600 million metric tons of hydrogen
into helium every second
temperatures need to reach about 14
million kelvin in the solar core for
fusion to ignite because the hydrogen
atoms have to have enough kinetic energy
to overcome the repulsive forces between
them it's this fusion that makes the sun
a star rather than a planet
the magnetic field of the sun holds
crucial clues for understanding solar
activity
if you've ever heard about sun spots or
a solar flare then you have some
familiarity with what solar activity
means
sunspots are cool patches that sometimes
appear on the sun's surface showing up
as dark spots thanks to their lower
temperatures
we think that sunspots form thanks to
the sun's tangled magnetic field lines
to understand how this happens take a
look at the sun with standard magnetic
field lines drawn connecting its north
and south magnetic poles
it's a simple illustration and the
magnetic field lines look nice and neat
but we've forgotten something the sun
spins
it also spins at different rates with
the equator moving faster than the poles
this varying rotation distorts and
curves the sun's magnetic field lines
you can try something similar by picking
up a piece of string and twisting it
between your fingers in opposite
directions
eventually you'll see twisted loops pop
out of the increasingly twisted string
those loops that you've made are a
pretty good representation of how the
sun's magnetic field can cause sunspots
those magnetic field loops will
sometimes protrude through the sun's
surface producing cool spots where they
poke through which we see as sunspots
this is why sunspots tend to come in
pairs you'll see one spot associated
with the end of the loop that's closer
to the northern magnetic pole and
another for the southern magnetic pole
the number of sunspots on the sun's
surface increases and decreases on an
11-year cycle
the sunspots themselves make very little
difference to anyone on earth
they have only an extremely tiny effect
on the sun's brightness so the solar
cycle won't have any impact on things
like our planet's climate and could
never cause something as severe as the
climate change we've seen in recent
years
still solar activity is worth
understanding for another reason
the solar activity cycle also correlates
with the number of solar flares and
coronal mass ejections that we see from
the sun
solar flares are eruptive events that
release light and charged particles
spectacular events that if they're
strong enough can disrupt satellite
communications
coronal mass ejections have the
potential to cause even more problems
these are explosions of material in the
sun's atmosphere that can send massive
blasts of particles from the sun's
corona hurtling toward earth
solar astronomer richard carrington
recorded an immense burst of solar
activity in 1859
that became known as the carrington
event
he first noticed a large number of
sunspots on the sun's surface
followed by an enormous geomagnetic
storm
at the time the telegraph was the most
widely used form of long-distance
communication and the storm was powerful
enough to wreak havoc with the system
some telegraph operators were shocked by
their equipment and communication towers
hurled sparks
in desperation some operators turned off
their haywire equipment
only to realize that the telegraphs kept
working even after being unplugged
suggesting that an eerie amount of
charge was still present even in the
ambient air
now imagine something on the scale of
the carrington event happening today
in a world where we are incredibly
reliant on satellite communications and
electronics even with solar astronomers
closely watching the sun we wouldn't
have much warning and there's not much
we can do
currently emergency plans focus mostly
on what to do in the aftermath
setting up emergency equipment to get
our power grid back up and running
until we can predict events like this
well in advance and execute emergency
shutdowns to keep our satellites and
electronics safe we're stuck with
watching and waiting
when solar eclipses occur
parts of the earth are in the moon's
shadow
now because the earth is much bigger
than the moon a solar eclipse doesn't
happen all over the earth just at a
single location where the moon happens
to block the sun
it turns out that solar eclipses can be
quite different depending on where the
moon is in its orbit
this is because the lunar orbit has a
bit of an ellipticity to it so there are
times in the moon's orbit when it is
closer to the earth than others
this ellipticity is very small and hard
to see if you draw the moon's orbit to
scale
but it does make the measured extent of
the moon slightly bigger or smaller in
earth's sky
at its closest point to the earth known
as perigee the moon measures about 12
percent bigger compared to when it's at
its farthest point from earth or apogee
full moons at their perigee are
sometimes called super moons whereas
full moons at apogee are called micro
moons
and these small changes make a big
difference when it comes to solar
eclipses
when the moon is at apogee it can't
fully block out the entire sun
all we get is what's called an annular
eclipse where even the most complete
coverage still leaves an outer edge of
the sun exposed making the sun appear
like a ring around the moon
we only get total solar eclipses when
the moon is close enough to earth that
it can block out the entire sun
during its 10 billion years on the main
sequence the sun's mass loss has been
and will continue to be quite low
it has lost only a hundredth of a
percent of its mass over the past 4.6
billion years
that works out to an average mass loss
rate of one earth mass
every 150 million years
this mass loss is driven by the solar
wind emanating from the sun's outer
atmosphere known as the corona
relative to the bright disc of the sun
the corona is very faint
it is only visible to the naked eye
during the few minutes of a solar
eclipse when the sun's disk is
completely covered by the moon
such events are rare the corona was a
spectacular revelation to many americans
when the solar eclipse of 2017 crossed
the united states
the solar corona has a temperature of 2
million degrees kelvin and a density
that is just 1 trillionth that of the
sun's surface
the corona's hot tenuous gas is an
ionized plasma of mostly electrons and
protons
it is heated by activity associated with
the sun's magnetic field such as
sunspots and solar flares
due to this heating a wind of coronal
plasma continually escapes the sun
at a velocity greater than the speed of
sound
at the 1au distance of the earth from
the sun the solar wind has been measured
to reach a speed of 750
kilometers per second
this high velocity wind slows to
subsonic speeds when it begins to
interact with the denser gas in the
local interstellar medium
similar to the flow of water around a
source in a sink this turbulent
interaction region is known as a
termination shock
in the case of the solar system it is
located at a distance of about 90 au
from the sun
a bit further out is the so-called
heliopause where the solar wind pressure
has declined to the point where it
equals the pressure of the local
interstellar medium
launched in the 1970s the voyager 1 and
voyager 2 space probes respectively
crossed this threshold in 2012 and 2018
at a measured distance of 120 au from
the sun
thus the solar wind bubble produced by
the sun currently has a radius of only
two thousandths of a light year
in about five billion years the sun will
leave the main sequence as its core runs
out of the hydrogen necessary to power
its nuclear fusion into helium
as this now helium core begins to slowly
contract and heat up due to gravity it
will ignite hydrogen fusion in the
hydrogen-rich region around the core
this hydrogen shell burning will produce
much more energy
in response the sun will increase in
size by a factor of 200 and become a red
giant star with a surface temperature
that has cooled by a factor of two to
three thousand kelvin
the outer atmosphere of such a huge star
is cool enough for small solid dust
drains to condense out of the gas
the star's gravitational hold on its
bloated outer atmosphere is weak enough
that the star's radiation pressure on
these grains can push them into a slow
wind that escapes the red giant with a
speed up to 30 kilometers per second
the resulting mass loss drives these
grains of star dust along with some gas
into the interstellar medium
as a red giant the sun will lose about
one earth mass every 300 years due to
this process
such a mass loss rate is 500 000 times
faster than when the sun is on the main
sequence
overall during its 1 billion years as a
red giant the sun will lose about 50
percent of its mass
near the end of its red giant life
nuclear fusion will have left the sun's
interior with a mostly carbon core the
size of the earth surrounded by a helium
fusion shell and a hydrogen fusion shell
the helium burning shell can have
extreme fluctuations in its energy
release
these fluctuations drive episodic
thermal pulses that will eventually blow
off the sun's outer envelope over
thousands of years
during this time the sun will lose mass
at an average rate of one earth mass
every month
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here